[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit heinz
wolffs marietta slomka guten abend für
nachrichten journalisten stellt sich an
diesem wahlabend die frage ob man es
schafft zur nrw wahl eine moderation zu
formulieren und der nicht die begriffe
bevölkerungsreichstes bundesland und
kleine bundestagswahl vorkommen was
offenkundig schwierig ist 13 millionen
wahlberechtigte konnten heute abstimmen
und schaut man sich das ergebnis an
fällt auf der abstand zwischen erstem
und zweitem platz zwischen cdu und spd
ist deutlicher als erwartet schauen wir
als erstes auf die allerneusten zahlen
die hat matthias braun oft so ist das
marietta wir schauen auf die neuste
hochrechnung 21 uhr 45 und da sehen wir
die cdu bei 35,8 prozent mit zugewinnen
die spd bei 26,6 prozent und recht
deutlichen verlusten die fdp 5,7 prozent
6,9 punkte verliert sie die afg 5,6
prozent auch mit verlusten bei der beide
parteien sind aber im düsseldorfer
landtag vertreten
das war nicht immer klar heute abend die
grünen 17,9 prozent mit sehr großen
zugewinnen 11,5 punkte und die linke
sehr deutlich nicht drin mit 2,1 prozent
jetzt schauen wir mal was das heißt für
die sitzverteilung im landtag von
düsseldorf 199 sitze davon gehen an die
cdu 78 an die spd 58 an fdp und afd
jeweils 12 und die grünen 39 sitze wer
kann in dieser konstellation mit wem
regieren wofür würde es reichen das
sehen wir hier absolute mehrheit bei 100
sitzen dass es diese senkrechte linie
die man erreichen oder überschreiten
muss im moment regieren hier in nrw cdu
und fdp die kommen auf 90 sitze das
reicht also nicht damit ist diese
koalition abgewählt schwarz-grün 117
reicht deutlich rot grün sie 99 der
fehlen drei sitze das reicht also nicht
und die ampel aus spd grünen und fdp
wenn die denn politisch überhaupt jemand
will die kammer auf 109 und auch das
würde reichen übrigens die
wahlbeteiligung sehr deutlich gesunken
um neun prozentpunkte auf 56 prozent und
das nutzt tendenziell der cdu dankeschön
matthias für diese zahlen interessant
das bleibt noch spannend in nrw mit den
beiden spitzenmänner von cdu und spd
spreche ich gleich auch noch aber erst
mal blickt thomas münten auf diesen
wahltag in nordrhein westfalen
andreas tyrock ist der chefredakteur der
westdeutschen allgemeinen zeitung seine
einordnung des wahlergebnisses riesen
morgen die meisten nordrhein westfalen
zum frühstück heute abend ist das keine
leichte sache was die koalition angeht
wird es sehr spannend wir reden über
eine richtungsentscheidung wäre hätten
über das ziel rot grün oder eben ampel
mit druck aus berlin die zahlen sprechen
eigentlich eine klare sprache hendrik
wüst und seine cdu liegen mehr als
sieben prozentpunkte vor der konkurrenz
die prognose um 18 uhr endet in tosendem
beifall
dementsprechend selbstbewusst der
amtierende ministerpräsident
werde jetzt auf die demokratischen
parteien zugehen und ich werde alles
dafür tun dass unser land gut durch
dieses schwierige zeit kommt und
verlässlich regiert wird noch
selbstbewusster können die bündnisgrünen
den sonntagabend begeben ergebnis
verdreifacht monat neubauer kann sich
schon mal von ihrem parteiamt
verabschieden ohne grüne
regierungsbeteiligung geht nichts dem
größten bundesland
das ist ein riesiger riesige auftrag an
uns dass das richtig was sagen die
grünen wahlkämpfer zu den ungeahnten
möglichkeiten
umfragen sagen ein rot-grünes kabinett
ganz oben auf der wunschliste
ich will jetzt keine was vorschreiben
aber ich fänd's gut wenn die grünen nähe
zur spd suchen würden uns dann nochmal
die grünen punkt in düsseldorf in
nordrhein westfalen verstärkt darstellen
können nächsten jahres stell dir vor es
ist wahl party und der jubel brandet auf
als es zu beginn des abends heißt dass
die fdp eventuell nicht in den neuen
landtag einzieht herzlich willkommen bei
der spd die herzkammer der partei sei
das größte bundesland sagen sie hier
wenn das so ist gebe es dringenden grund
für einen besuch beim kardiologen
es gebe allen grund für demut klingt
aber anders ich denke eine rot-grüne
regierung könnte noch eine chance haben
und das war eine richtige regierung dass
seine progressive ist eine starke
regierung als thomas kutschaty kurz nach
halb sieben auf die bühne kommt klingt
der beifall nicht nach wahlverlierer
kutschaty schon anfangs
das ergebnis dieser landtagswahl ist
leider nicht so wie wir uns das
vorgestellt haben es gibt zwei parteien
die zugelegt haben nämlich die union die
etwas zugelegt hat und die grünen die
ihr ergebnis vor dreifach darf dann aber
treffen thomas thomas sprechchöre den
ruhrgebiets münchen und schon klingt es
anders
auch wenn die cdu vor uns liegt die
grünen ganz ganz stark zugelegt haben
sage ich an der stelle auch sehr
deutlich die sozialdemokratie nordrhein
westfalen steht bereit auch für eine
landesregierung hier im parlament von
nordrhein westfalen das genaue gegenteil
die stimmung bei der fdp knapp drin
trotzdem eine mischung aus entsetzen
schockstarre und letzte hoffnung ampel
bundes kurs in düsseldorf naja wenns
sein muss die haben unsere telefonnummer
die können anrufen werden wir zum
gespräch bereit bleibt noch die afg auch
knapp drin aber deutliche verluste die
linken wahlparty war kurz und
schmerzvoll der landtag für weitere fünf
jahre verschlossen der abend endet mit
einem wahlsieger der vielleicht trotzdem
nur oppositionsführer wird bekannten
telefonnummern und cdu anhängern die
eigentlich feiern möchten sich aber
nicht sicher sind ob es dazu grund gilt
und das fragen wir hendrik wüst gelernt
mirko slomka eigentlich immer an sich
finden genug grund sich zu freuen heute
abend
absolut ich bin sehr sehr dankbar für
dieses starke ergebnis die wählerinnen
und wähler haben ein klares wort
gesprochen und uns einen klaren
regierungsauftrag gegeben sehr sehr viel
vertrauen für meine partei und für mich
und wir werden in den nächsten tagen
beginnen die gespräche mit allen
demokratischen kräften zu führen das
blöde ist nur dass ihnen der
koalitionspartner abhanden gekommen ist
wie konnte das denn passieren
wir haben in den letzten jahren sehr gut
und erfolgreich auch vertrauensvoll und
verlässlich mit der fdp gemeinsam
regieren ich freue mich dass unsere
partner auch im nächsten landtag
vertreten sind wählerinnen und wähler
haben heute zwei sieger ausgemacht
nämlich unser cdu und auch die grünen
meinen herzlichen glückwunsch an die
grünen ihre spitzenkandidatin wo der
neubau er aber die fdp die ist jetzt
nicht mehr in der regierung also sie
haben im prinzip ihren
wunschkoalitionspartner verloren war es
vielleicht auch nicht so hilfreich dass
sie da dann in den letzten tagen auch so
ein bisschen in richtung schulpolitik
stichwort bildungssoli fdp gestänkert
haben
der auftrag der wählerinnen und wähler
ist klar wir wollen eine regierung
anführen ich werde mit allen
demokratischen kräften im landtag
sprechen mit wem wir die zukunftsfragen
gerade in diesem land beantworten können
da geht es um nicht weniger als um die
versöhnung von klimaschutz und
industrieland also viele wichtige themen
in den nächsten tagen zu gesprächen aber
wir sind an mit den partnern
zusammenarbeiten mit dem das am besten
geht na ja was ist denn nordrhein
westfalen ist jetzt nicht
schleswig-holstein also sie können jetzt
nicht wie kollege günther ist sich
aussuchen sondern sie brauchen sie haben
zumindestens partner die sie über den
notwendigen 17 überbringen das sieht
doch eigentlich sehr nach den grünen aus
oder
wir sind alle gut beraten dieses klare
ergebnis des heutigen tages mit respekt
demut oder mit anstand anzunehmen und
dieses ergebnis ist eben sehr klar in
nordrhein westfalen haben ein klares
wort gesprochen wer in zukunft die
regierung bilden und führen soll dh sie
werden sie setzen auf die grünen und
dass sie jetzt nicht plötzlich dann doch
noch da irgendwie in der ampel unterwegs
sein wollen
ich werde mit allen demokratischen
kräften die im landtag vertreten sind
sprechen und ausloten mit wem wir
gemeinsam die großen zukunftsfragen des
landes beantworten können darum geht's
jetzt aber noch einmal wir brauchen ja
entsprechende sitze also sie brauchen ja
eine mehrheit sie können ja nicht
einfach sich aussuchen mit wem sie
sprechen
die fdp reicht nicht mehr ich glaube wir
werden alle miteinander sprechen ich
gehe auf alle demokratischen kräfte zu
und dann werden inhalte darüber
entscheiden wie die nächste
landesregierung aussieht klar ist für
mich es muss eine konstellation sein die
klare antworten gibt auf die großen
fragen dieser zeit und die bereit ist
verlässlich miteinander fünf jahre lang
dieses wichtige land zu regieren
man mit den grünen wird das schwieriger
und anstrengender werden wahrscheinlich
als mit der fdp denn bei fast 18 prozent
wollen die ein gehöriges wort mitreden
also da werden sie gewaltige kompromisse
machen müssen
die zentrale frage ist klimaschutz und
industrie miteinander zu versöhnen dazu
braucht man wirtschaftliche kompetenz
und ökologische kompetenz und das muss
gewährleistet sein ganz gleich mit wem
man nachher regiert und da muss man
nicht es geht gar nicht kompromisse ein
gemeinsames projekt auflegen dass die
richtigen antwort auf diese große frage
geben
und dann wechseln wir direkt zur
konkurrenz sozusagen der hat auch noch
ein projekt thomas kutschaty guten abend
nach düsseldorf
hallo show guten abend an ihren ampel
ambitionen halten sie dann noch fest
oder haben sie sich in der letzten
stunde irgendwie um entschieden die
letzte hochrechnung da kam die spd nicht
mal mehr auf 27
naja feststeht cdu und grüne haben
deutlich dazu geworden deswegen
herzlichen glückwunsch an diese beiden
parteien aber schwarz-gelb ist abgewählt
worden wir müssen jetzt eine neue
mehrheit finden im nordrhein
westfälischen landtag und da ist es gut
dass alle demokratischen parteien jetzt
miteinander gespräche führen und wir
sind selbstverständlich mit dabei wir
wollen auch gespräche führen und sagen
auch das ist ein projekt was noch nicht
abgeschlossen ist ich darf sie damals
zitieren ich halte es für sehr an maßen
von armin laschet sich aus dieser
historischen wahlniederlage der union
einen regierungsauftrag herleiten zu
wollen um sie selbst nach der
bundestagswahl gesagt aber jetzt gilt
das irgendwie nicht historische
niederlage aber trotzdem
regierungsauftrag
jona ist schon ein unterschied ob man
nach 16 jahren bundesregierung abgewählt
worden ist und über acht prozentpunkte
verloren hat oder die situation jetzt in
nordrhein westfalen hier hat das ist
überhaupt nicht vergleichbar der bereich
jetzt geht es doch darum hier in
nordrhein westfalen eine regierung zu
bilden die die wichtigen
zukunftsaufgaben lösen kann mehr geld in
bildung zu investieren
bildungsgerechtigkeit zu organisieren
die energiewende einzuleiten mehr
bezahlbaren wohnraum zu organisieren und
zu bauen und da muss man jetzt gucken
wer kriegt da die entsprechenden
mehrheiten zusammen die so stimmt das
als parallel oder als vergleich nicht
ich meine nrw das war mal ein stammland
der spd bei der letzten bundestagswahl
standen sie auch noch sehr viel besser
da als jetzt also das ist doch genau so
niederschmetternd eigentlich wie für die
cdu verlorenen bundestagswahl
wir haben aber nicht 16 jahre hier am
stück regiert da war der wunsch sehr
sehr deutlich dass die union nicht mehr
regieren soll wenn sie sich jetzt die
umfragen anschauen vor der wahl wer soll
denn die nächste landesregierung
anführen welche koalition ist denn die
gewünschte
regierungskoalition in nordrhein
westfalen da haben die menschen sehr
deutlich gesagt dass soll eine spd
geführte regierung seien rot grün
möglichst das wird wahrscheinlich nicht
reichen nach der sitzverteilung aber
ampel ist auch noch ein beliebtes modell
bei der bevölkerung gewesen also eine
schwarz grüne regierung oder sie sagten
doch eben die fdp ist abgewählt worden
aber sie würden sie dann quasi doch noch
in eine regierung mit reinnehmen
womöglich dann auch noch mit dem
bildungs frisur dass hier eben als sehr
wichtig betonte
das ist eine frage die hat die fdp jetzt
erst mal zu klären inwieweit sie bereit
ist regierungsverantwortung wieder zu
übernehmen das kann ich ihnen jetzt
heute nicht beantworten
mit der fdp um mit allen anderen
demokratischen parteien jetzt
entsprechende gespräche
sind sie denn wenn sie jetzt wollen sie
die fehleranalyse gehen irgendwas ist ja
nicht gut gelaufen bei der spd sie
hatten so viel unterstützung von kanzler
scholz kann es sein dass diese
unterstützung nicht wirklich hilfreich
war
nein das ist nicht der fall gewesen wenn
sie sehen wo wir vor einem jahr waren da
war mir den umfragen ihr nordrhein
westfalen bei 17 prozent dass wir jetzt
sieben prozentpunkte zugelegt haben hat
unter anderem damit zu tun dass wir
rückenwind von der bundesregierung von
der bundes partei bekommen haben das hat
uns massiv unterstützung deswegen bin
ich auch sehr dankbar für diese hilfe
aus berlin wo wir darauf achten müssen
ist dass die wahlbeteiligung so
dramatisch runtergegangen ist in
nordrhein westfalen nur gut jeder zweite
ist noch zur wahl gegangen
offensichtlich unsere stamm wählerin und
standbilder nicht mehr so sehr wie die
der union und das müssen wir jetzt noch
einmal genau anschauen was da nicht
richtig gelaufen ist
danke für das gespräch und
dann schauen wir jetzt auf die
politischen reaktionen in berlin die
sind nämlich den ergebnissen
entsprechend die cdu freut sich die spd
versucht sich nicht als verlierer
sondern nur als zweiter sieger
darzustellen haben wir ja gerade auch
gemerkt fdp chef christian lindner muss
schon zum zweiten mal innerhalb einer
woche eine herbe niederlage erklären
während die grünen zum zweiten mal laut
jubeln können die afg versucht sich
ihren abwärtstrend schön zu reden
während die linke nicht verbergen kann
dass sie in den abgrund schaut david
gebhard mit dem berliner analysen er
stand nicht direkt zur wahl in nrw doch
olaf scholz war stark präsent auf spd
plakaten und wahlkampf doch der erhoffte
scholz effekt verpufft die verluste
seiner spd heute hat sich der kanzler
damit quasi selbst angeheftet die
bundespartei am abend redet sich das
ergebnis schön setzt weiter darauf auch
als zweiter die regierung in nrw für
platz eins hat es leider heute abend
nicht gereicht was ich ihnen aber sagen
kann ist dass wenn wir die chance haben
in nordrhein westfalen eine koalition zu
bilden die für bessere bildung für
bezahlbares wohnen für den
klimaneutralen umbau der industrie steht
dann bieten wir als spd an diese chance
zu ergreifen
die spd hofft ein bündnis etwa eine
ampel gegen die cdu zu schmieden die auf
platz eins sieht sich bundespolitisch
gestärkt und in nrw klar am zug die
stärkste kraft hat den gestaltungs und
regierungsauftrag das ist die
christdemokratie unter der führung von
hendrik wüst die grünen sind starker
gewinner dieser wahl die gute arbeit der
ministerinnen und minister hier in
berlin hat rückenwind gegeben für die
grünen herzlichen glückwunsch umgangs
versuche lob aus der cdu für die
regierenden grünen die als einzige ampel
partei gewinnen und nun für cdu oder spd
königsmacherin sind geht nicht darum
hauptsache regieren sondern es geht
darum mit den richtigen inhalten zu
regieren und davon werden unsere
entscheidung abhängig machen gar nicht
gut bekommt dagegen der fdp ihre ampel
beteiligung bei den jüngsten
landtagswahlen - fünf schon vergangene
woche in schleswig holstein heute -7%
lange zitterpartie ob man überhaupt rein
kommt ein trauriger abend sei das sagt
der parteichef ein statement zwischen
trauerrede und trotz wir haben eine man
muss es so sagen desaströse niederlage
heute abend zu verzeichnen klar ist aber
auch wir sind freie demokraten deshalb
haben wir klare überzeugungen und wir
haben vielfach bewiesen dass wir starke
nerven haben und deshalb geht die arbeit
auf der bundesebene weiter ein
bekenntnis zur ampel eines angefasst
parteichefs und finanzministers bitter
der wahlabend auch für die linke die
weiter verliert deutlich an der
fünf-prozent-hürde scheitert und die afg
die es zwar knapp in den landtag schafft
aber unter parteichef kino copala bei
der neuen landtagswahl in folge verluste
einfährt da werden wir uns die nächsten
tage natürlich auch unterhalten müssen
inwieweit wird jedoch eine initiative
west auch hier brauchen als kleine
bundestagswahl gilt der urnengang in nrw
und so ist der widerhall laut bis nach
berlin zu hören bei der opposition links
und extrem rechts verschärft sich die
krise und die ampel wacht morgen früh
wohl mit einem kater auf
so war in nordrhein westfalen jetzt ein
kommentar von chefredakteur des zdf
peter frey
die grünen haben hochkonjunktur
während spd und fdp von der ampel
koalition in berlin nicht profitieren
können das ist das bundespolitische
signal aus nordrhein westfalen heute
abend habeck und bernburg sind zugpferde
ein nennenswerter scholz effekt für die
sozialdemokraten ist nicht zu erkennen
die fdp verliert im land von christian
lindner geradezu katastrophal
wie ungleich die drei partner hier
abschneiden das wird die bundesregierung
belasten die niederlage der liberalen
hat vor allem landespolitische ursachen
stichwort bildungsministerin aber es
summiert sich die fdp hat nun bei allen
drei wahlen in diesem jahr schlecht
abgeschnitten keine steuersenkungen
immer neue milliarden-schulden das
gefällt ihrer klientel nicht und es
kommen andere faktoren hinzu die
eigensinnige corona politik und der hang
in sachen ukraine und sicherheitspolitik
gleichzeitig regierung und opposition
sein zu wollen wie die geborene
düsseldorferin marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann
bitter die verluste auch bei den
sozialdemokraten statt eines neustarts
in ihrem kern land fährt die spd mit
thomas kutschaty ihr schlechtestes
ergebnis ein angesichts des großen
abstands zur cdu wirkt es wie
realitätsverlust dass die parteiführung
heute abend dennoch chancen für rot grün
oder eine ampel regierung sieht es gibt
zwei wahlsieger heute abend die grünen
mit ihrem beeindruckenden comeback und
den schnellstart hendrik wüst der
gewinnt hinzu stärkt damit den cdu
parteivorsitzenden friedrich merz und
wird wenn es ihm gelingt die grünen zu
sich herüberzuziehen die chance auf die
poleposition als nächster kanzler
kandidat der union haben schwarz grün
ist heute abend die wahrscheinlichste
option für nrw gewiss das wäre eine
zumutung für viele grün wähler aber die
starken grünen könnten die cdu zu einem
energischen klima umbauprogramm zwingen
schwarz-grün im großen nrw das könnte
auch eine alternative für die
bundestagswahl 2025 aufzeigen dieses
signal tatsächlich aus düsseldorf zu
senden obwohl sie damit misstrauen auch
bei ihrem ampel partnern sehen das ist
der preis des grünen erfolgs
peter frey kommentierte und jetzt heinz
wolf mit den nachrichten er richtet sich
der blick zunächst die ukraine und da
einmal mehr auf das umkämpfte mario pohl
und das belagerte stahlberg also stall
die hölle ist auf die erde gekommen so
ein mario polar stadtrat und
veröffentlicht dieses video ein
feuerregen über den also stahlwerk in
dem noch ukrainische soldaten
eingekesselt sind es soll mit
phosphorbomben beschossen worden seien
heißt es von ukrainischer seite
unabhängig bestätigen lässt sich das
nicht denn jetzt die separatisten und
russische kriegs korrespondenten
hingegen sollen von angriffen mit brandt
raketen gerichtet haben
nach den schüssen in einem supermarkt in
buffalo im us-staat new york gehen die
behörden von einer rassistisch
motivierten tat aus das zeigen demnach
die ersten ermittlungen zu dem
festgenommenen 18 jährigen der aus einem
hunderte kilometer entfernten ort nach
buffalo gefahren sein soll um die tat zu
verfügen der supermarkt liegt in einer
mehrheitlich von schwarzen familien
wohnten gilt der täter tötete zehn
menschen und verletzte drei weitere
im libanon ist ein neues parlament
gewählt worden das land im nahen osten
befindet sich seit jahren in einer
schweren wirtschaftlichen krise es gilt
aber als unwahrscheinlich dass die
politisch verantwortlichen
abgewählt werden zudem begünstigt das
politische system eine fortsetzung der
machtaufteilung zwischen den etablierten
parteien der schiiten sunniten und
christen beobachtern zufolge ein grund
für die geringe wahlbeteiligung
ergebnisse soll es morgen geben
dass die ukraine den eurovision song
contest gewonnen hat dank eines starken
votums des europäischen publikums ist
natürlich eine moralische unterstützung
die in dem land glücklich aufgenommen
wird auch ukrainische soldaten jubelten
und präsident selensky versicherte sein
land werde den esc im nächsten jahr auch
ausrichten die ukraine will natürlich in
ein land einladen in dem dann keine
bomben mehr fallen nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg sagte heute dass er glaubt
dass die ukraine den krieg gewinnen kann
derweil hat jetzt auch die schwedische
regierungspartei für einen nato-beitritt
bestimmt damit stände der aufnahme
schwedens und finnlands eigentlich
nichts mehr im weg wenn sich nicht die
türkei claire stellen würde was man im
kreml vermutlich mit freundin beobachtet
florian hahn berichtet am mittag als die
außenminister der nato hier in berlin
noch tagen passiert plötzlich einer
entschlossen davon es ist der türkische
außenminister sagt seine regierungen
etwa nein zur nord erweiterung der
allianz dieselbe frage stellt sich in
helsinki auch der finnische präsident
gerade hat er den beschluss seine
regierung verkündet sich um die aufnahme
in die nato zu bewerben und berichtet
dann von seinem letzten telefonat mit
dem türkischen präsidenten erdogan kitu
cup teamchef hat das thema dann selbst
aufgegriffen und mir gesagt dass sie
bewerben sich doch für die nato und wir
werden das positive bewerten
daher verstehen sie sicher dass ich
jetzt etwas verwirrt bin einmal mit
computer womit er nicht der einzige wäre
zurück in berlin familienfoto beim
ministertreffen der nato nicht nur das
war lange eine eher lästige pflicht
russlands krieg hat alles verändert nach
jahren in denen es in den nato
mitgliedsstaaten gerade auch hier in
deutschland
vertreterinnen und vertreter gab die die
nato als überholtes auslaufmodell
gesehen haben erleben wir jetzt leider
auf die absolut brutalste art und weise
warum es eben die nato eine sicherheits
und verteidigungs und braucht den schutz
der nato brauchen sie jetzt so glauben
sie auch in schweden wo sich am abend
die hier regierenden sozialdemokraten
für den beitritt zur allianz ausbrechen
was sie dafür brauchen ist die
zustimmung aller 30 aktuellen nato
staaten und in berlin so berichten
mehrere diplomaten wird die
außenministerin aus dem noch nicht nato
land schweden vom außenminister aus dem
nato land türkei heftig angegangen heute
nach seinem applaus stellt der oberste
türkische diplomat dann bedingungen
darunter etwa ein härteres vorgehen
gegen die kurdische pkk oder
rüstungslieferungen in die türkei das
ist keine verhandlungsmasse das ist eine
voraussetzung für ein bündnis
das klingt wenig versöhnlich und umso
überraschender wirkt die zuversicht des
nato-generalsekretärs
die türkei hat klargestellt dass eine
blockade nicht ihre absicht ist
29 nato partner sind sich einig in
berlin es soll jetzt schnell gehen mit
der nord erweiterung und es soll bitte
nichts dazwischenkommen auch nicht der
dreißigste partner
und jetzt nochmal eins mit sportlichen
meldungen von diesem wochenende nach
schalke 04 hat auch werder bremen die
direkte rückkehr in die fußball
bundesliga perfekt gemacht wenn gewann
heute 2 zu 0 gegen jahn regensburg und
beendete die saison auf platz zwei auf
platz drei und damit in der relegation
der hamburger sv
ein herzschlagfinale nennt sich das auf
fußball deutsch was mindestens bis zur
halbzeit in darmstadt und in rostock
aufgeführt wird wo die gastgeber gegen
den hamburger sv früh in führung gehen
währenddessen steht es bei denen mit dem
hsv punktgleichen darmstädtern gegen
paderborn nach 38 minuten schon drei zu
null zu diesem zeitpunkt wäre darmstadt
mindestens platz 3 sicher doch der hsv
kann schon in minute 50 durch torjäger
glatzel ausgleichen und in der 75 minute
dann die so wichtige führung durch
schonlau er kaufmann mit den dritten
hamburger tor den umworbenen
relegationsplatz sichert das zweite
rostocker tor änderte daran nichts mehr
was weiter geworden ist hätte er ihn und
ich denke die schäden verschaffen in
bremen wird platz zwei und damit der
direkte aufstieg durch das ungefährdete
2 0 gegen regensburg gesichert und
ausgelassen gefeiert
die meisterschaft in dieser zweitliga
saison geht nach gelsenkirchen den
nürnberg erzählt simon terodde mit
seinem dreißigsten treffer für schalke
das siegtor zum 2 1 und am montag steigt
vor der schalker arena die große
offizielle aufstiegsfeier
der vfl wolfsburg trennt sich wie es
heißt einvernehmlich von trainer florian
co fällt der 39 jährige hatte den posten
erst im oktober übernommen ein
nachfolger wurde noch nicht benannt
große freude beim fc bayern münchen das
team von trainer julian nagelsmann hatte
sich die meisterschaft vorzeitig
gesichert und heute dann die feier mit
meisterschale auf dem münchner
marienplatz
10.000 fans jubelten der mannschaft zu
für die bayern ist es der zehnte titel
in folge und insgesamt nur 32
und jetzt noch wie immer sonntags unser
ausblick auf die nächste woche mit
ereignissen die sich jetzt schon voraus
sehen lassen oliver reichert hat uns da
einige termine zusammengestellt
[Musik]
am montag läuft in ganz deutschland die
volkszählung zensus
2022 an mehr als 30 millionen menschen
sollen befragt werden wer ausgewählt
wurde ist zur teilnahme verpflichtet
am dienstag werden die filmfestspiele
von cannes eröffnet um die goldene palme
konkurrieren 21 filme aus russland und
aus der ukraine
der petersberg bei bonn wird ab mittwoch
für drei tage zentrum der
internationalen finanzwelt die
g7-finanzminister und -notenbankchefs
treffen sich mit blick auf den rhein
am donnerstag wird der bundeskanzler
eine regierungserklärung abgeben vor dem
eu gipfel ende mai geht es um die
energieversorgung die sicherheit und um
russland
um den dfb pokal geht es am samstag
finale der herren im berliner
olympiastadion der sc freiburg spielt
gegen den rb leipzig und
jetzt die wetteraussichten zum start in
die neue woche morgen ist es östlich der
weser und in ostbayern freundlich sonst
ziehen von westen schauer und gewitter
mit unwettergefahr durch starkregen auf
die temperatur erreicht 20 bis 28 an der
ostsee 17 grad am dienstag gibt es
schauer und gewitter im südosten der
mittwoch wird sonnig und so beginnt auch
der donnerstag später gibt es gewitter
im westen dabei ist es warm wie im
sommer 22 bis 32 grad
das war es von uns sagen diesem sonntag
mit krimi geht vielleicht weiter und um
0.35 gibt es dann die nächste heute sind
und hier erwarten sie morgen abend
christian sievers und anna zimmermann
auf wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]